ماذا يقول الحوثيون عن
هذه الغارات الجديده ضد
مواقعهم نعم حسن بحسب بيان صادر من موقع
المسيره التابع لجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين فقد قالت ان عدوانا امريكيا
بريطانيا قام بشن ضربتين جويتين على معسكر
الجبانه في شمال مدينه الحديده ولكن مصدر
عسكري مصدر من قياده انصار الله الحوثيين
اخبرني بان هذه الضربات هي استهدفت معسكرا
قد تم قصفه مرارا وتكرارا من قبل التحالف
الذي كانت تقوده السعوديه خلال تسع سنوات
الماضيه وان هذا المعسكر لا يمثل شيئا
وانه لا لا توجد هناك ايه اضرار ماديه او
بشريه قد لحقت بالقوات العسكريه وقلل من
هذه الضربات ووصفها بالعبث هذه هذه
الضربات تاتي بعد يوم واحد فقط من قيام
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين باستهداف سفينه
امريكيه في خليج عدن وهي منطقه بعيده
نسبيا عن مواقع سيطره الجماعه وهي تقع ضمن
سيطره الحكومه اليمنيه المعترف بها دوليا
وتاتي بعد تصريحات من قائد الجماعه عبد
الملك الحوثي والذي قال ان سلاحا نوعيا قد
دخل الى المعركه وان على الامريكان ان
يفهموا ان هذا السلاح النوعي قد ربما يدخل
في خلال الفترات او الايام القادمه اذا ما
استمرت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
باستهداف مواقع مواقع عسكريه او مدنيه
داخل اليمن بحسب تعبيره هذه الهجمات يقول
قاده انصار الله انها تاتي في ظل في مناطق
تسيطر عليها جويا الولايات المتحده عبر
مدمرات وبارجع المنتشره في البحر الاحمر
وخليج عدن وانها تستهدفها من خلال اسلحه
نوعيه قد دخلت لاول مره وهو تصعيد جديد
نوعا ما باستهداف هذه السفن التجاريه في
عمق خليج عدن وكذلك في بحر العرب وهي
مناطق تبعد مئات الكيلومترات عن مناطق
سيطره جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين ابقى
معنا سمير لنسمع من فادي منصور ما يقوله
الجانب الامريكي عن هذه الضربات الجديده
على هذا
المعسكر نعم حسن فضلا عن ما اشرنا اليه
سابقا نقلا عن مسؤول امريكي حول توجيه
ضربات لمواقع يسيطر عليها انصار الله
الحوثيون في اليمن وبالاضافه الى تصريحات
جون كيربي منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه
مسؤول دفاعي امريكي ابلغنا بان مقاتلات
امريكيه على الارجح انطلقت من عت حامله
الطائرات ايزنهاور ك قامت بعمليات قصف
لمواقع داخل اليمن استهدفت ودمرت ثلاثه
صواريخ مضاده للسفن وفق هذا المسؤول هذه
الصواريخ كانت تمثل تهديدا وشيكا على
الشحن البحري في منطقه البحر الاحمر
بالاضافه الى قوات البحريه الامريكيه هذه
الضربه هي المره الرابعه عمليا التي تشون
فيها الولايات المتحده غارات عبر الطائرات
او ضربات عبر صواريخ توما هوك ضد مواقع
يسيطر عليها انصار الله خلال هذا الاسبوع
اي اربعه ايام من اصل خمسه ايام انطلاقا
من يوم الثلاثاء الماضي وحتى اليوم وهي
بمجموعها عمليا المره السادسه التي تشن
فيها الولايات المتحده هجمات ضد انصار
الله الحوثيين في اليمن انطلاقا من يوم
الخميس من الاسبوع الماضي عندما بدات
الولايات المتحده بالتعاون مع بريطانيا
بشن هذه الهجمات اليوم وفق هذا المسؤول
الضربه قامت بها الولايات المتحده على حد
من من دون مشاركه من القوات البريطانيه
ورغم تاكيد البنتاجون انه لا يريد ان
ينزلق الى ضربه مقابل ضربه او هجوم مقابل
هجوم الا ان وقائع هذا الاسبوع تبرز اننا
دخلنا في هذه الدوامه الولايات المتحده
وتحديدا في البنتاغون هناك اقرار بان هذه
الهجمات التي تقوم بشنها الولايات المتحده
لم توقف هجمات انصار الله التي تعتبر
الولايات المتحده انها لا تفرق بين
السفن والبحاره وانها لا تتعلق على
الاطلاق بمساله غزه ولا تؤثر على مساله
الحرب داخل قطاع غزه لكن على الاقل هذه
الهجمات التي تشنها القوات الامريكيه تقود
من قدره انصار الله علما اننا راينا ان
الهجمات من داخل المواقع التي يسيطر عليها
انصار الله في اليمن استمرت والتطور
الابرز خلال عمليا هذا الاسبوع او تحديدا
بعد الضربات الاولى الامريكيه ان انصار
الله بداوا يستهدفون الشحن البحريه
الامريكيه